we see the deal go through there's been
talk of this merger for some time let's
just start with a simple question why
now
thanks gelatin a great to be in the
program
well why now I think we have been as she
said looking at at BG for for a long
period of time on enough it was always a
a match that really worked well in our
minds to companies coming together if
you look at what integrated gas or LNG
and deepwater could be if he would
combine the two add to that the
capabilities that we have as a leader in
two areas this was always going to be a
fantastic combination now what happened
over the last month's of course it was
that the macro-environment involved to a
to a point that not only was this a
great logic but it also became a very
very compelling value so together with
the value that we see in combining the
value that we see in the synergies this
became something that looked too good to
pass up on and that's why we removed as
we did in this period and just to follow
up on that you say the macro-environment
helped the evaluation of this deal is
that an expensive way of saying the
collapse of the old price helped drive
this deal well of course the the
collapse in the oil price has done quite
a bit for her for the sector of course
consolidations always tend to happen
when the oil price comes down and there
is a and there is a different valuation
the way we would look at it though is if
you look at the combination of the two
companies what we could do with the
assets the fantastic assets that BG have
with our capabilities applied to them we
simply saw a whole lot more value in
that combination than the market saw in
the marketplace so therefore that value
drove the logic of the deal at this
stage but it looks like for shell this
is a pretty big bet on gas why the big
bet on gas and as the CEO how do you see
natural gas is role in the next 20 25
years in the global energy mix yeah very
good question Jonathan I think you know
it's it is indeed a a bet on gas but in
that sense the company is a very very
important guest company as well so we
are about at this point in time she'll
stand alone
fifty/fifty company when it comes to gas
and oil and really combining it with wit
BG will not change that ratio
fundamentally so yes indeed it will be a
much enhanced integrated gas company but
we see gas also is a very very important
fuel for the future bear in mind this is
a fuel that does 50 percent less carbon
dioxide emissions than coal in power
generation and we therefore see gets to
be very very important bricks or even a
destination fuel for many decades to
come so we think a bet on gas is a good
thing is this signed sealed delivered do
you see any big hurdles going forward to
get this deal through well there will be
has been any deal of this magnitude will
of course be approvals that we will have
to go through so the key approvals that
we have identified are of course Brazil
because that's a very large portfolio
Australia China and of course we will
have to go to Brussels as well I think
the key ones are going to be the these
four probably but Brussels being the
least complex one because the the
overlap is is or the complementarity is
easiest in Europe it will take time
Jonathan but we are confident if people
get through this otherwise you would not
have embarked on it it will take us
probably until early quarter one next
year before we can complete but I just
want to talk about the price paid very
quickly as well 47 billion pounds do I
look at that or do I look at the premium
if I look at the premium it kind of
looks a little bit expensive a 50
percent premium I was looking at some of
the deals through the Bloomberg dates or
anything over ten billion dollars
typically in this sector carries a 40
percent premium what was the thinking in
the price paid well you have to really
look at this on the basis of of a net
asset value place so you look at the NPV
of the assets how it's being valued at
this point in time what that NPV would
be worth or rather what these assets
would be worth if there were combined
with ours that's the way you typically
do this on Lachi and P deals now this is
a super large C and P deal but if you
look at it this way you look at what
this asset set is worth for the combined
company and how it's being valued in the
market
there is a huge gap in valuation are
some of that you have to give of course
to shareholders in the form of the
control premium but the premium really
is resultant again if you look in the
sector a premium of 50 percent this
pretty much sort of middle of the road
but if you look again at what it does
for the sort of key metrics of the
company you will see it is immediately
going to be a creative in terms of
operating cash per share earnings per
share is going to be accreta from 17
onwards significantly a creative from 18
onwards and in terms of free cash flow
is going to be very seriously a creative
almost immediately as well and that of
course is driving the logic of the deal
together with the fact that we'll use
this as a springboard to divest
significant parts of their large group
to make it a much more focused company
and return that to shareholders as well
yeah you talk about earnings per share
of course that might be flooded somewhat
by that 25 billion dollar buyback
between 2017 and 2020 what is the
thinking behind that buyback well the
thinking is as follows we want to have
not only the sort of basic logic of
putting two portfolios together and then
really work the value out of it by the
capability of shell we want to have also
this deal as a springboard for making
the company much more focused much more
simple much more straightforward so what
we aim to build is a company that has
three core pillars a very very strong
world-class deep water business a very
very strong world-class integrated gas
energy business and then some very very
strong cash engines as well it's being
able to do up to twenty billion dollars
of cash per annum by the end of the
decade and then there's some long term
options now what we're going to do is is
significantly streamlined therefore the
existing portfolio and we think that
about 30 billion dollars worth of assets
will be sold in a process in the 16 to
18 period that's
together with the increased operating
cash together with a much disciplined
approach to capex will basically make a
lot of free cash flow available that we
return back to
holder's first of all by diffident then
you know a dividend policy but on top of
it a very significant buyback 25 billion
dollars which will offset part of the
script or dump out the entire script but
on top of it we'll also start paying
back the equity issue that people have
to do to complete this deal Ben I'm very
sorry but we have literally 30 seconds
left so this won't have to be a quick
one you buy BG we are looking at anyone
else when you were looking at making
this deal the likes of BP for instance
are we've been looking at of course a
range of companies for a long time but
this by far is the most compelling deal
because think of not just for us for the
industry Ben Vandiver and great to have
you join us this morning Ben van Beurden
the CEO of Royal Dutch Shell